[Music]
I cannot believe you guys have never
played a VCR game before they were
really popular in the okay they're never
popular but they tried to make the
popular in the 80s how does it work it's
a board game but with a video we know
those overly complicated games that
nobody could follow except for that one
smug asshole uh-huh
well here the smug ass was a VHS tape
sure about that yeah all set up
go ahead hand me that a VHS there wait
this isn't a game Aragon came out in
2006 what impossible yes basically my
book written by that eighteen year old
that impressed people cuz it read like a
book written by an eighteen year old no
no there's no way this was an actual
movie movies have something unique a
style even bad ones have something that
separated from the elders trust me this
is just a generic fantasy game with a
million generic fantasy clichés like a
million other I don't know critic I
remember being advertised and everything
okay look I'll put it on to show you oh
sorry sorry I need this room for my
papers the best game should always be
awake homework
[Music]
greetings adventurers Seattle just
nothing to be taken this seriously john
malkovich isn't i am the evil king
Galbatorix
with my minion Durza i will rule all of
allegation see how serious this is
supposed to be with all those names
begin your adventure with Eragon yeah
even though it wasn't a big hit Eragon
still holds a place in people's memories
it's a story of swords and princesses
and Dragons and absolutely nothing else
no nothing really separates it from a
million other fantasies and myths that
you've heard a million times to a point
where it's kind of intriguing but again
to be expected from a VCR game from the
80s
I'm telling you Critic it's a 2006 movie
next you'll be telling me he worked at
Stefan hmm begin your quest at the
beginning where you begin okay fine I'll
go through the whole thing just to show
you it's simply a generic fantasy video
game I never said I want it to do that I
also recall no interest in this plan
let's go through and see what's wrong
with this mr. piece your eyes even
looking at we're down here let's take a
look at Eragon who are you talking to
right now
allegation was ruled by men
astride mighty dragon ooh a dragon film
with Jeremy Irons that opens with white
clouds
oh god no hide every working winds and
for thousands of years the people
prospered fun fact this is what
Inspector Gadget sees every time he
unzips his pants oh I can't help how my
perverted mind sees the world yes you
can then they just don't want to there's
apparently a handful of people known as
the dragon writers who make pies the
name is deceiving and speaking of
deceiving a young writer betrayed them
ah this must be the villain from
powerful group that used to be friend
but turned evil traitor he killed all
the dragons and writers and rules with
an iron fist covering his mouth try not
to laugh at his own name since then
land has been ruled by Galbatorix I
swear that sounds like a foreign soup
Galbatorix yes I'll have a bowl of the
Galbatorix cut to the force of ancient
port color Corrections where we see a
fleeing writer named Aria a girl has no
dragon film there it's out of the way
let's continue
she's ambushed by the Kings minion Durza
played by Robert Carlyle and for a guy
who had to look like this in once upon a
time he still seems pretty silly here oh
my god this would be amazing if it
turned out this was all just the nyquil
and before the story started I will
relieve your nighttime sniffling
sneezing coughing aching even she
teleported away to Lu Jimmy Kent who
figures he might be able to sell it to
quit being Downton Abbey's first footman
[Music]
okay so if he swallows that the story
ends and he wakes up in his bed
believing whatever he wants to believe
it might kill him if he swallows it but
I say that's worth the risk actually
this is our title character Eragon
played by Edie spellers mmm the poor
good-looking farm boy who dreams of
adventure there you see what movie will
be that bare minimum with its main
character well maybe there's other
defining traits about there I know other
defining traits about him I'm really
learning that to like this guy it's John
Malkovich eazy-e's do it what many men
seek is often right under their nose but
for some the unknown is too hard to
resist yeah that must be the gruff uncle
looking after the main character after
something happened to his parents I
can't wait to see him they get all the
way to the end he lives with his uncle
and cousin in the shitty Shire where
they let's see yep yep insert playful
action sequences posing as character
bonding why I discovering that he enjoys
fighting and gets along with his cousin
oh look
two birds and me with the stone
Wow that not only miss but it was both
boring and awkward but it looks like his
cousin named ro ran is off to join the
king's army and work on that aim you may
make a hunter yet which one is going
again we look so much alike I sometimes
forget who we are yeah I'm really gonna
miss the way he fought for a minute and
said he was gonna join the army and then
join the army all in the family has
nothing on these dynamic relationships
the Harry Potter jelly bean hatches
though giving birth to a bouncing baby
Spyro what a stain I think very good
Eragon the more I know dragons a few
select people feel their connection
though making Arya's budget saving
invisible chains even tighter where is
it too late my time has come here
shivers down my spine body's aching all
the time thus Eragon discovers all sorts
of things about his new pet cool you did
you pushed my hand really hard on a
cinnamon bun good hahaha
I smell a DreamWorks spin-off how too
lame your dragon and in an ironic twist
Jay Baruchel will voice the Dragon
Christ it's like the grounded up gizmos
fed it to that baby from storks and then
farted out a pregnant bolts will gave
birth to this
thus were finally introduced to the evil
Galbatorix played by transformers threes
master of subtlety john malkovich i
suffer without my stun do not prolong my
suffering
wait isn't John Malkovich that
pretentious actor who isn't good but
everyone has to pretend is good for some
reason if you're at this scene you are
probably talking about my acting right
now but as long as I am Keith gather my
army and follow them many people would
say I enunciate too much and speak in a
patronizing tone that even patronizing
toads would call patronizing tone Jesus
I believe the technical term is milk
spoiling but I do this because for half
of my life I was a mute wow we never
knew that thus if it looks like I am
showing off how I just learned how to
talk it's because I am do not prolong my
suffering do not let them reach the
Varden don't I say everything like I
just learned how to speak and flaunting
it I am NOT interested in being
challenged to remind those who resist my
rule I know you mock me but I am just so
excited to hear words coming out of my
mouth that I have to relish it when the
Varden learned that the legend is real
disloyalty will be punishable by death
so please be kind to my performance but
everything else about me you can mock
that's fair we'll take it so you know
how this goes Eragon has to raise the
dragon over the course of months even
years to establish a strong connection
with her
door that they grow up so fast I guess
we can still go off the basic connection
they started to establish when the
dragon was younger Grom was right Eragon
the time of the Dragon Riders has come
again
done this isn't gonna work we now have
Rachel Weisz playing the dragon who
calls herself Saphira communicating
telepathically with our hero why first
off well there's usually nothing wrong
with Rachel Weisz in general wouldn't a
cape blanch shed or Helen Mirren or
Angelica Houston or somebody with a more
commanding voice make more sense I keep
expecting this voice to ask Georgia the
jungle to save her I have waited a
thousand years to hear your thoughts
second their connection is surprisingly
weakened once he can hear her
we had them originally connecting
through silence and that was working out
fine granted there wasn't a lot of time
to it but you know I was on the right
track suddenly out of nowhere you go
from a baby to a grown-up so not only is
that practically a different character
but now there's a different form of
communication as well so it disrupts the
natural flow of their relationship third
and most importantly she says nothing of
importance throughout the entire film
yeah every once in a while she'll
explain something in a sentence but it's
something he or one of the other
characters easily could have explained
even if you want to go the route of a
mental bond it would be made stronger if
it was left open what and how she was
saying it we don't need it spoon-fed to
us
think of a timeless connection like
lassie almost the same setup a boy and
his pet would that be nearly as good if
we could hear the dogs thoughts I do not
wish to take the vitamins they taste
like horse meat and death Lassie Martin
I'll give you the three to come out my
last name is Martin what why who keeps a
dog the last
- I will shit in your mouth while you
sleep tonight
see what I mean okay so she says he is
meant to be her writer he doesn't know
what to think of all this so he goes to
Brahm an old merchant played by Jeremy
Irons is it true yes I will do any movie
tell me about the dragons are you cool
to your fears ah this must be the quirky
old mentor the teacher who used to be
the thing the hero wants to be you and
the uncle should look into real estate
you've got such long lives ahead of you
speaking of which uncle Owen I will be a
Jedi I mean a knight I mean spider-man I
mean whatever the hell link is you did
nothing to cause this I'll kill you
anyway
very funeral I'll decorate him in eleven
herbs and spices when we get back I'll
get on that horse who are you right now
Thank You mr. right now my uncle's
Kentucky Fried funeral will not go
forgotten so our main character begins
his quest what was it actually I don't
know I mean things are set up there's a
bad King he has a dragon I guess bad men
are after him but in terms of what the
actual goal of his quest is if it's
mentioned it's not made very clear the
surprisingly is not super uncommon for
example the world isn't very
well-defined
I mean you see a shot from Avatar you
know you're on Pandora you see a chef
from Wizard of Oz you know you're in Oz
this could be anywhere
middle-earth Fantasia that Warcraft
movie nobody saw nothing separates it as
unique but again I shouldn't be too
harsh after all it is shot beautifully
for a VHS game critic at some point you
have to realize this isn't an especially
high-end video for kids it's an
especially bland theatrical release for
suckers yeah it's trying to be something
we've never seen but instead it's
everything we've ever seen well that's
just gonna lose you Malkovich
enunciation points isn't it Malkovich
naima video I can't hear you
oh sorry it's alright so they start
their quest to
find their quest he's gone okay cool
finally some action in this movie I feel
like this took forever I have skills
right then let's see these skills of
yours so it's the same action we have
before two good guys playfully fighting
while no real conflict is going on you
know this will be virtually
humor me yeah I see the effect of your
failure just keep joking those people
are probably dead but still you gotta
laugh it's fun
whoopee Oh cousin Roran you're fighting
I hope you wouldn't stay you suck let's
go sad to say there's actually a lot of
what you just saw for a while they sit
down and talk they ride on horses they
sit down and talk they ride on horses
and even when they do sit down and talk
all I'm thinking is how much more
interesting it would be if the Dragons
shut the hell up like look at this scene
a dragon will only hunch if it feels the
presence of its rider what he says is
true
a rider will live on that his dragon is
killed but if a rider dies so dis is
dread
yeah it's generic it's nothing it leaves
no impact now let's try this scene again
except take out the dialog and see if
not only do you get across what she was
saying but do you actually read even
more into it a dragon will only hatch if
it feels the presence of its writer
a rider will live on that his dragon is
killed but if a rider dies wasn't that
more interesting wasn't it cooler when
you had to feel what she was trying to
get across rather than be told but don't
worry even when they do get to exciting
scenes they don't do them right
when they finally fight some soldiers
it's so dark and shaky you can't even
make out what's going on Aragon gets so
ticked off he lights up the scene
through his goddamn will alone but I ins
tells him I believe it's magic magic
comes from dragons it flows through the
riders oh come on no I'm just kidding
it's midi-chlorians before you cast a
spell you must learn the ancient
language of the elves what's the word
for tree tree is Trevon well that's a
happy coincidence what's the word for
hand hand Vaughn and the branch branch
Vaughn haven't you been listening so
they figure if he's gonna be a dragon
rider he should ride a dragon yeah I can
totally hear you up here rah rah that's
all I'm hearing out of me right
ah this must be the evil black monster
people who make annoying sounds for no
reason always an obnoxious addition wow
that's the first man I've ever killed oh
never mind going over here now effects
by industrial lighting come on I thought
we agreed not so light oh my god will
you shut up I'd use the term show don't
tell but I'd rather replace him both
ways shut up shut up where's your dragon
she was murdered
with this sword that sword is a dragon
killer oh is that why he said he killed
a dragon you had nothing and while she
was trying to protect me my dragon was
killed
better we
then I ride us again watch the scene
with the dialogue cut out instead of
listening to her just repeating what's
already been said read her facial
reactions where's your dragon she was
murdered
with this sword and while she was trying
to protect me my dragon was killed again
night and day I don't care if the
original book has this or not here it
turns an interesting relationship into a
standard relationship and that's not
what you want from a fantasy that's
trying to stand out but could be worse
could be made even more standard by
throwing in a princess meeting rescuing
up a head of course and you will notice
her suffering and torment psychically
sending images to Aragon of her twirling
in the forest and skipping to pleasant
imagery that doesn't sound like torment
that actually sounds really nice it is
totally not nice it is to show how brave
she is by portraying peaceful imagery
even though she's suffering sure you
didn't just want to work in some
whimsical forest porn that's trademark
of fantasies now yeah I even see it in
commercials you could slap a shampoo
logo over and I assure you it is deep in
stuff as Jeremy Irons says in this scene
if I don't you be killed yes this is
sacrifice she's happy like yeah how can
someone be happy to make a sacrifice
doesn't that technically make it not a
sacrifice mmm I don't know is what I
would say if this was a video where you
could hear me which it is not can we
turn this off
[Applause]
[Music]
you
hey big news everybody we're doing
another theatrical premiere of one of
our reviews and it's in time for a
nostalgia weed we're doing a clipless
review of the remake of Stephen King's
it and this time it's two nights October
4th and October 5th in Woodridge
Illinois at Hollywood Boulevard theater
tickets sold out super fast last time so
you definitely want to get them as
quickly as possible this is a wonderful
theater where you can get meals and
alcohol we're gonna be there signing
autographs and answering questions just
go to the link below and get your
tickets there they go super fast we hope
to see you there
so we're we gone journeys to rescue the
princess and oh Christ
even though castles are boring who
designed that place the guy who made
diehard batteries Hey
he sneaks in by wearing a robe so he can
blend in with whatever the hell those
were world building as he makes it to
her cell but I stopped by Durza I
expected someone a little more
well more I mean he Fletcher from a
Knight's Tale could kick your ass a
young magician how quaint Wow somebody
actually gave a writer a paycheck to
have their evil villain say how quaint
they even gave him a close-up on that
line they were so impressed by it
how quaint come on we have plenty of you
should have killed me while you had the
chance or you and I are not so different
or go the extra mile but bronze
sacrifices himself for Eragon don't
worry he was more than happy to do so
and Sapphira comes in to see they decide
to go to a group that could use Eragon
and his dragon for good but not before
Brom says his last words you know before
you technically took it away from me
it's a complicated game
haha my last words are calling you an
idiot
so they bury Brahm on top of a mountain
oh why no monologue explaining why
you're standing on two legs
no long-winded bullshit explaining what
we already know come on we can still
have her blurting out the obvious a hero
has died I am sad
Walter is wet dirt is brown my paycheck
is plentiful but it turns out someone's
been following them a young rebel named
Murtagh I'm mother tongue and you need
me dragon right now thanks but I'll be
fine without you
why would you turn him away it looks
like you hoped you back at the castle
he'll he's been following you without a
dragon and somehow kept up you have an
inter princess with you and just lost a
rider there is literally no reason not
to use him ah ah this must be the young
possibly untrustworthy rogue trying to
gain trust except there's nothing
untrustworthy about it oh wait it's
revealed he's the son of a traitor sorry
the strip got these two pages backwards
oh this is the order was meant to be in
well in that case you're dumb he is the
son of Morrison the traitor son doesn't
choose his father nor explain who he is
who are we talking about he's a traitor
okay like he killed an entire army or
took your turn at call of duty what
amount of judgement do we give to this
but things like emotional connections
aren't important we have to get you um
let's see ah here we go
the bad guy giving his threatening
speech to the holy cow
tonight we destroy the races
Oh little dears I put on mommy's makeup
all by himself
[Music]
what was that dent here
you shouldn't whisper when you want a
canyon full of men to hear you I was
height now I'm just trying to figure out
what he said what toys are fine
the evil armies do attack and Eragon
gets ready to fight okay not gonna lie
dragon armor looks goddamn ridiculous
one name you choose a leader for his
heart without fear there cannot be
courage but when we are today's you're
talking there's literally people being
slaughtered you really picked the wrong
times not to fight but they make their
way down to helms deep shit and try to
fight off the armies give that guy some
credit he's on fire and he's still doing
his job
I will atone for whatever my father did
and I will rule My Kingdom or whatever
it is I want to do I will something
something something dragon our
motivations are clear but ugly Loki
arrives and Eragon tries to finish him
off Oh much like your sword that joke
was full of iron good night folks
Saphir is having trouble though so
Eragon tries to use his magic to save
her sadly though it looks like there's
bad news sure some friends can't be
replaced
luckily some don't have to
what a dick yeah that's what you get for
not stopping them from imprisoning me
little asshole so what do we accomplish
an army fought princess saved a dragon
born and yet I really don't know what
this all was supposed to amount to what
arcs were supposed to have taken place
here that I haven't seen done better in
a million other unique fantasies will
Arya at least bake him a cake did you
know the people of the burden already
tell stories about you cliched stories
with literally no surprises time moves
quickly I mean yesterday you were a farm
boy today you are a farm man and just
when it looks like it's all happily ever
after
[Music]
oh no the biggest surprise of the movie
yes
that I have a dragon - no no that we
already knew yeah it was one of the
first lines in the movie oh well what
were you surprised by then that you kept
the dragon behind a map yeah who does
that does he have a bathroom back there
a treadmill for walks aren't you afraid
if he sneezes he'll set the map on fire
you know what I don't need this
I've been hacking your screen to talk to
you and it is not easy wait there's no
way you can hear us No
hey guys anybody know who this is
I said what are you doing well I was so
embarrassed to be in this film I thought
it'd be better if I made you think it
was a VCR game from the 80s so wait this
wasn't just a VHS game it actually was a
cinematic movie we told you bitch I'm so
confused it's not like it's the worst
movie there's some pretty sites and most
of the actors do well most of them it's
clear there was effort put into this but
there's absolutely nothing new how did a
story and dialogue this by the numbers
and so behind the times get made it
doesn't feel like a fantasy movie it
feels like a fantasy game where the
story is more a side note to get to
something else only in this we never get
to that something else it's almost kind
of tragic it's clearly trying very hard
but it has no message or ideas that's
worth trying hard to say it's not awful
it's just not good
well that is Hollywood for you wait
aren't you gonna fish the game what did
you hear it's fake yeah but a mediocre
movie makes fun okay VCR game and I want
finish this no I'm sure I'm getting an
award somewhere for something oh
I mean another malkovich to close us out
with fantasy clichés anybody knows
someone that does impressions and thus
my evil rule was thwarted but even more
was on the horizon like the prophecy of
destiny the romance between the rich
girl and the poor boy who can't have her
finding the treasure of someone dead
you know John Bailey I don't think this
is working maybe this is just lame no no
it's cool I can do a face wipe to look
more like it
behold my Malkovich nice now where was I
oh yes totally original fantasy stuff
like coming across a group of ragtag
fighters who don't get along the army
who looks like they have no chance but
are then saved at the last minute a kid
from suburbia suddenly getting
teleported to a magical realm the
villain who is somehow related to the
hero a magical little person who is
either funny or annoying the hero
becoming ruler of the land even though
he has no understanding of government
simple societies being right and
complicated societies being wrong a
woman who disguises herself as a man a
chosen one with a birthmark a twist that
everybody could see coming a device or
monster that's going to take over the
world the pretty place with pretty
people who are good and the ugly place
with ugly people who are bad minions who
are idiots sidekicks who are idiots
something tiny that is actually very
powerful don't read too deep into that
unless you feel it makes it more epic
hey guys guys you still there John
Bailey slowly hung his head in shame and
returned to his own YouTube channel
you
do not prolong my suffering
hey guys Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing the American Humane Association
their mission as a network of
individuals and organizations is to
prevent cruelty abuse neglect and
exploitation of children and animals and
to assure that their interests and
well-being are fully effectively and
humanely guaranteed by an aware and
caring society American Humane envisions
a nation where no child or animal will
ever be a victim of willful abuse or
neglect as a recognized leader in
professional education training and
advocacy American Humane joins with
other similarily missioned individuals
and organizations to make their vision
of reality there are tons of videos on
their youtube channel from not just
everyday people who are helped by them
but celebrities too who talk about so
many amazing people and animals and
their tales of survival check out their
site and their YouTube channel to see
how you can make a big difference
[Music]
you